this is a joint work with natan so it's
a again a checkpoint
attached
so today we're going to talk about the
goodness of fit for a multi-class
prediction at first who am i
a i'm a senior data scientist for trust
ai trust ai is a
startup that we're doing a
data science omitting basically we're
doing sensitivity analysis and
ensuring that
that ai systems are reliable and won't
do any
bizarre stuff
in this point we are focusing in the
financial market but
we but we have more i have a phd in uh
applied math from the technion and
although my supervisor was she was she's
actually this is
from the
a television
and so
and so my interesting in data science
math algorithm if any of you want to
contact me for anything
uh
feel free
this is my email
feel free to contact me okay
so
where can we find the
multi-class like the most trivial thing
is you might argue that it's in the
e-commerce like you go to website you
can buy a shirt you can buy pants you
can make shoes those are different
target and
and so you want to score them
and
another motivation is from the cyber
security because
before we saw one type of attack but
as earlier mentioned there's many
different way to attack a cyber so
basically
we need multi-class and each class is
different
the motivations
for for me was entering was the iot
robot i was working
as a consultant
i was working consultant
for a
for detecting
which kind of grain were grounded
i know it sounds totally none ai but
there was a problem they don't know and
so they had lots of classes they had
coffee they had beans they had nuts and
they want to know which one is
which one is
is they getting grounded and it turned
out to be a hard question and this is
where i got in the picture and at first
i thought it's a trivial because
everybody know that and i started
googling it and and all the answers i
got were not
satisfactory but somehow we made that
another issue that you might think about
is predictive maintenance if you bring
into the
the wrong technician with the wrong gear
it can cost lots of it's going to be
very in unpleasant
so
why do we care
first of all
we we there's the issue of
a fair ai
and if
that is getting really strong and
the multi-class is a
huge issue there uh detecting weak sex a
segment is
very important a
robust robustness of the classifier and
of course if you're doing adversarial
example if you spotting out at one of
those classes for some reason is
the classifier
mismatch it it's a very
good start for your adversarial example
so let's say reveal
a few methods that
are known there's a one against all
usually when there is one
important class in the rest like you say
that the
militians and non-militias this is one
way of attacked
it usually works well when you know
which
class is important if you don't know
it's worked that well so then they have
the second day
approach is
it's all against all it's just like
fight club when they arrange
when everybody is arranging
in pairs all possible pairs and each
pairs are just a
fighting each other and then you average
things up so
this is what the second day method
is sometimes you can do hierarchy like
let's say here like you a movie it can
be a comedy and then it can come in the
action and it's hierarchical and it's
one approach
thus another approach is a we assume
that all the classes can be somehow
embedded in some kind of a latent
euclidean space and then your
multi-class problem becoming a
regression problem and everybody's happy
if anyone knows how to do this say
embedding i'll be happy to learn because
then usually we have no idea
so
our
assumptions uh we don't know the
prevalence like we don't know if there's
one class is more than the last we have
no idea and we don't know each hierarchy
we don't know the embedding and instance
must be in one
class and there's one thing that
distinguished a good a
and experienced data science in in a
beginning a beginning data center said
okay no problem let's ask the domain
expert
but then when you learn your expertise
you learn that you're that the domain
expert don't give a damn about you
so we you can ask you can ask but he
won't be available as way
you wish he was so
so our approach is that we know nothing
okay let's start with the binary case
binary case
one positive you're negative
and in the binary case we all know this
type 1 error and type 2 error a type 1
error when a male gets
diagnosed as pregnant a type 2 is when a
pregnant woman is a
diagnosis is not pregnant we will i
think all of you saw this slide
somewhere
okay
uh the confusion metrics
uh
it's kind of one of the basic
which is a true positive true positive
those who you predictive positive and
they are positive a false positive
you're predictive positive but they are
negative false negative are predicted
negative but they are positive and true
negative are predicted and
and so the main problem is that
our pro our data is unbalanced
so basically many
way
many things are not suitable like
like many methods are mountboard and
accuracy
the accuracy might
mislead us
so basically those let's go to those
reveal those cases
uh what is accuracy accuracy is how much
we write
a recall is the if
if we predicted positive
it's really positive to predict motive
precision if we predicted positive real
positive specifically if it's real
negative and predicted negative
given predictive negative and
npv
negative predicted value
which for some reason doesn't have a
nice name
the recall has another name sensitivity
but the npv doesn't have any name and
since we all love pandas
everybody love pandas
and
so basically we can if we have a
accuracy function we can rewrite this in
pandas say if we don't
okay
okay let's do a little bit recap about
means
this is algebraic mean just taking
divided to the geometry thing you you
multiply and
and take the square root
and you remember the
the yes the harmonic mean is going to be
up next and
we have the harmonic mean and the the f1
score
as probably all of you know are is the
harm is the harmonic mean of the recall
and the precision
changes in harmony so why do we take the
harmonic mean this is one of those
classic job interviews questions
the smallest of the three thank you very
much
the harmonic mean is the
it is the smallest of the algebraic a
geometric and harmonic the smallest one
so basically taking the harmonic would
be a good bet
okay let's ask
if if if we have only a negative
predicted we predicted every
our target value is zero our predicted
value is zero what would be our accuracy
yes and what would be our f1 score
anyone else
no no
anyone anyone else want to guess they
say one one one anyone else want to give
a try
how would the way psychic learn
and
there's this would be one and this is
zero
and anyone who's doing a testing testing
in a.i should they realize that
and the interesting thing is that
there's a discontinuity
this discontinuity might be a little bit
problematic in some cases
so
beware
uh
anyone who's familiar with scikit-learn
and there's f1
0 and f1 one
which is they're taking kind of a
generalizing is that the f one one is
what we know and the f one zero is uh
specified in the negative predicted
value
and the reason we take that is that we
want to see
both for the negative and the positive
and
matthew correlation coefficient
brian matthew was a biostatistic
biochemist was from australia he's from
a suburb of adelaide
and
he he decided that defining this metric
would be the geometric mean of the
of the predicted and the the throughput
the true positive predicted a a
a positive and
and if we take this math and we take the
determinant of this matrix
we get a classifier there's a few
recently there's a few
a papers that they test the f1 and the
matheus and
usually in most aspects the matthew is
superior
so if you're
thinking which one to use
i recommend to take the matthew
so let's remember what why are you
taking them determinate
if you remember that the term what is
the geometric meaning of the determinant
is the area
of two two so basically if we have this
matrix we want this matrix to cover as
much
area as possible
this is the geometric meaning remember
that in the multi-classes this intuition
would be very useful
and
a
if we're taking the
a
the correlation the pearson correlation
between the target and the predicted
we're getting again the matthews
which is
a nice result
and vice versa
it's vice versa he calculated
correlation
yeah yeah this is massive calculate
correlation got the the math is but
but it's an
it's a nice uh
result
and there's another
metric which is the auc of the rock
curve and just you take
the threshold and you play with that and
diary i don't
it's a little bit
off scope here so forgive me that i'm
going to not
go more that okay let's started to think
about
multi-class we came here for multi-class
not to see a recap about the two
to the two classes so
we want
a multi-class metric and this metric
first of all it's got to be classes we
renaming if like if you remain rename a
class and or the order of them you want
the same result
the if you want intuition if you if
though spoke about gnn one of the main
things about jnn that you want to be
invariant to
nodes order and the same here think
about those those classes as kind of
nodes you want if someone is playing
with them you want the same result and
the second
thing is
is that that you want to flip the target
and the
the target and the predicted why do you
want that
the reason that you want that
is that it's
it's a the equivalent of a non-biased
classifier like if you want to take
a non-biased a regressor and
there's lots of statistics say
good stuff that occurs if you take that
and you want the same for for those
classifiers
if you want this
full analog ghost you need to use this
the second property otherwise it won't
happen
so
a
the multi-class
has a confusion matrix as well just like
you think it would have
and well the first approach is
taking f
1i taking for each class
i can take the some kind of a a harmonic
mean of the chance of
predicted i in real i and real iron
predicted i it's kind of one against all
approach
and i have this fi if i take some kind
of a
reasonable average
i think i implemented the in the code
the with harmonic mean but you can use
any
average that you like which
we we stated in the paper
uh some
some way how to define a reasonable
average but it's a but if you want the
algebraic harmonic everything is
geometry everything is good or if you
want to pick your own one
eh
okay
i'm sorry this slide isn't the setting
here is a little bit
yeah of course it's actually this is
this uh it is nothing fault nothing made
this slide well basically the square
what is the square uh forget about
formulas we want we have to
we have two vectors categorical and we
want to see and we want something
equivalent to a correlation but we don't
have a correlation for categorical
values so what do we do
we have some kind of a
association what is the association if
it means that if you're getting a
if the the
it's mean if two values are somehow
associated like if you if there's those
two vectors are independent it's mean
that they're not
associated at all and if they're
dependent so basically you can predict
one from another
it's mean that they're associated if
any one of you is doing eda which i
guess and every one of you is doing it
ada
i think using for categorical
features the
the association test is a good idea so
taking the square it's a it's a way to
measure how much those
two vectors are
are
dependent and we can go that
is a clamor camera was a swedish
statistician
and he said okay let's see how much that
the target and the predicted are
related
it's give some idea but not perfect why
not perfect because all of the
statistical measurements are you just
you you basically want to reject
hypothesis and and not be sure and here
you want to the other way so it's
it's a good idea it's a good approach
but not good enough
okay
so
we
and this is the main result of our work
we
took
we we took the geometric mean of a
metric the metric the the entry i j
metric would be the geometrical mean of
the i predicted a in the predicted j for
i we have this matrix
it's a symmetric matrix but not a
positive matrix
and if we take the determinant
we get a
the generalized massive correlation
and
why do we why are we taking the
determinant in more than a
two day in what why do you take
determinant that main intuition for
three dimension is volume in more than
that it's hyper volume it's a little bit
hard to
plot a four dimension so forgive me
okay
multi-classes
a
desirable metrics which desirable if
we're taking the average
if one i
it would be cool it would be it's a good
bet if like if you're wondering for a
multi-class the f1 j f1
good way the crammer
would be okay
the general matthews they were doing
that we can do the all against all
although
it's kind of
i don't like it that much because it's
it's a little bit overkill and you don't
realize if you have like those
some classes are a
are bullied other classes and in the
matthews you can really see that like if
one of those one classes is uh
is
doesn't get prediction or
math matthew realized other metrics
would be less sensitive for that
okay since we're in pi data i need to
show you a python code right
it's one it's part of the deal
and basically
it's a simple code i
i program it so it can't be that hard
and
so basically i'm using a
the harmonic mean and the geometric mean
of the
of
of psi pi
and
here i
took the
the
first i
calculated some kind of a
and
in the general if i i just took the the
trace
i'm interested in the only in the
diagonal so basically you might say
trace
and
in the matthews i'm taking the
determinate
and um crammer it is that it's really
implemented in a
it's implemented i think there is a
more compact a
way but i didn't i saw but there was
something that didn't like the way
it was from out of the box so
i wrote those four lines
any question about that code
you can see
it's a bit dark like
okay
so let's sum it up
before entering the questions uh
basically
i we saw we started we saw a
y multi class then we had a little bit
recap to
two classes
and then we defined what we want to see
in multi-classes
and we ended up in a few
examples of a multi-class a
metrics
and that's about it till your question
feel free
well actually you don't you don't have
such a situation and the reason is that
you
if if the numbers of classes in your
target doesn't match in the number of
of classes in your predicted
then something is wrong
because it either means that there's
some classes that didn't got any
predicted
and then
and then you just added a zero and then
you'll get zero and just like what you
want and the and the second option is
that you predicted something that was
not in the target
and this is not a desirable
thing is there so basically you can't
get er
so
if
you can't get a rectangular because we
assumed that
you're not adding and not omitting any
classes because doesn't make any sense
if you're having such like
so basically
it means
it means that you're a classifee
classify
think about that in a class in a
classification
a point of view and if you have
something like that it's mean that
you're doing a lousy job
no no it's mean that you can't
that they're predicting to the g so the
j class is just like predicting to the i
classes and and you and you assume that
your prediction is there makes sense so
basically you kind of assume
that the
you're targeting
when you're targeting eye to eye because
otherwise it's a you get
the metric would give you a lousy score
as stud
as it should
so basically your answer is
a
two categories of 2000 uh
no it's we're not talking about the
minor two of two of those we're talking
about the entire row so it means that
it's either you're not predicting to
those classes
uh
you can't distinguish if you can
distinguish between them it means that
something is wrong with your predictor
so you don't want that either so
so getting a zero it would behave
aligns theoretically
[Music]
sucks
yeah basically it means that much
actually because it's meant in from the
dominant perspective it means that the
volume of the power level height
the volume of the popular level zero
yes
and you don't want that
so so basically it tells you
that you're in a crappy situation
it may perhaps it may happen but it
means that you didn't and and you and
and you want to get a lousy score you
want to get a lot of scoring in such a
situation because it's not something
that your desire to
[Music]
[Music]
so are you about to release that code
this one yeah i can it's a negative it's
not on git you can if you want you can
uh you can license
under what license
not on what's licensed
the license would be as kindly and you
can use it
you can use those the eight lines of
code there as much as you like it's
that's good
thank you
how will you give some weight if the
model predicts i in 60 confidence
against the model predicts i in 90
percent confidence if i want to do so i
don't know because we're well the main
thing in multi-class instead of two
classes you're not focusing in one class
like it's it's the main the main focus
of this work is that you want to the
holistic way you you want to see the
entire classes
not only one classes maybe and and
but in way you're right if there's one
classes which sucks
the model would give you a bad score and
you want that and the reason that you do
you don't want a one class that
is getting bad score it usually means
that you have a fairness problem and you
don't want that trust me you don't want
that
in order to derive itself you should
follow the actually the dnn protocol
simply take one test and throw it a
thousand times
yeah you basically say that the
prediction is the highest percentage
don't mind the percentage that the model
gave you
some sense yeah
anything else
okay thank you
[Applause]